what up guys welcome back to another
episode of get close on bar and i'm geo
and today
we have one of the greatest grapplers of
our time
and i first saw you on instagram you
fell in love well not even on your page
but i think it was one of those like
grappling compilation pages
and i just saw this dude like being
extremely physical like taking jiu-jitsu
to a level of physicality i haven't
really seen before yeah slams and [ __ ]
like that and i started looking i'm like
who's this guy and i'm like oh [ __ ] the
black belt slayer
and so for me like i'm always rooting
for the underdog right so when i saw
that that and and he's he he's a huge
fan of violence so anytime yeah me
personally so anytime he sees anything
ultra aggressive he's like oh [ __ ]
that's calling my name yeah so like
seeing you win adcc as a blue belt
amongst a c or a silver silver medal as
amongst a sea of black belts
i'm like that's [ __ ] sick
well i i appreciate that i i do enjoy uh
violence as well you know i'm a
violence oriented kind of guy
i like to think that i americanize jiu
jitsu a little bit because i bring the
like
the you know
the state style wrestling tour towards
the brazilian style of jiu jitsu you
know i think
i think the two sports are kind of bound
to collide and i just so happen to be
kind of in the forefront of that explain
that to me a little bit so what's the
american style of wrestling and then
what's the brazilian style of jiu-jitsu
so international wrestling is like uh
freestyle wrestling where it's it's
mainly stand up uh some parts where you
turn your opponent
uh folk style or american wrestling is
um
there's a lot more map wrestling
involved so you take the guy down you
have to turn him to his back there's a
lot more scrambles that happen on the
map
in jiu jitsu it's mainly about the
scramble so
you take that and you add in submissions
and you have you know a tournament like
80 cc so
um i think i just took like the
aggressive wrestling mentality that like
the
mindset out i'm gonna be on top i'm
gonna smash this guy and uh and i took
that towards jiu jitsu and i think just
like right off the bat my my approach to
it like the intensity that i bring um it
was very like uh
it was kind of hindering to my opponents
you know they were a bit intimidated and
just because i think people aren't used
to training at like a high high pace or
like you know the kind of output that i
bring to competition it threw a lot of
uh black belts off and uh you know just
kind of paved my way and got on in there
did you uh train like that too like in
practice do you go like is it 100
yeah i i don't feel like i've done
anything unless i i feel like i've
destroyed my body that day like i want
to go as hard as i can every session uh
granted like there's days of the week
that you know like for me personally my
best days are usually like tuesday
wednesday thursday where i can go i can
treat it like competition go harder uh
and then you know that i have other days
where i'm banged up and i'll just uh i
focus on more technical aspects uh not
so much competition oriented but you
know uh kind of uh sharpening all the
tools that i have yeah i think it's uh
it's about balance for sure
um so when were you like oh [ __ ] my
style's actually really effective was it
like during practice where you're like
oh [ __ ] i'm smothering these guys so
like
so i started jiu jitsu kind of like on
an accident i was uh
i like just quit college after my
freshman year i was modeling a little
bit in the summer and i was like hey
that's not manly stuff
you're right you're right
you're like family stuff you're right
yeah call him out call him out tell me
that well you need money so yeah exactly
i need the money so i was modeling a
little bit i was like making enough
money to like
don't even say it like that because like
it's not like so a lot of people will
say they modeled and they're like
modeling for [ __ ] like penny saver
type [ __ ] like um you were actually
signed to like a pretty major agency
yeah i mean will amina if i'm i'm pretty
sure they're the biggest fitness health
and fitness models they're huge
yeah
yeah so i like i signed with them like
i did like a few photo shoots with like
instagram people i just dm them and they
were like all right well i'll shoot you
for free no problem i sent them my
photos drove up there and they're like
all right like we'll sign you book you
some some
some work and it's not like like male
models and i don't i don't know maybe i
make like i don't know 2 000 a month
which is like for me i have to drive
three i was in new york anyway so so
it's all going to gas and uh and food
anyway so
uh pretty much my summer after my
freshman year at college i was bouncing
working at home depot and like doing
modeling and stuff
um so while i was bouncing a few of the
guys were like
um
for a few years were trained jiu jitsu
and they were like listen we could we
could destroy you because you know we
did shits and you just wrestled i was
completely against that i was just a
bunch of [ __ ] talkers yeah just just a
bunch of [ __ ] talking so uh finally they
convinced me go to practice i trained
with them and the first time
[Music]
and the guy that owned the school was a
black belt and uh you know i trained
with them like they couldn't sell me at
all i just took them down
took their back like i didn't do
anything but you know i was on top and i
pretty much won i felt like i won what
was the uh guy that was challenging what
belt was he uh he was a purple but he
was a competitive purple belt so you
know he does like ibj jeff and stuff
which is pretty good he's a big guy he
was my size
um damn i mean he just [ __ ] whooped
his ass yeah right off the bat just just
with wrestling and then like i watched
ufc so i'm like all right if i stay out
of these bad positions i'll be i'll be
good to go was it in a ghee no no gee oh
i've i've put a gui on like
three times ever right almost almost
never put it you just never attracted
you just didn't like cut limits you the
the first time i wore it i like trained
a little bit and i just got burns
everywhere like my face was what i like
uh hey that doesn't sound manly either
dude
he's like i only play basketball with a
helmet on well you know what's more
what's more attractive than wearing like
a
is a jack dude shirtless true going
against the ladies hey all right all
right that's pretty badly my mind
the money there i gotta you know bring
in more attention so that's where i was
so was that like you're like oh [ __ ] i'm
kind of good at this thing i should like
stick to this a little more yeah so i
did the first training session and then
after that i hopped around like a few
different different gyms in south jersey
and um i found a home at south jersey
bjj where it was like i was having
tougher times with their black belts and
stuff so i commit there i trained for
like two weeks um and i met i meet a
coach uh
jay regabuto he's like dude you
shouldn't you should compete right
uh we do a competition in walwood i i
score like
no i was like 70 points to zero in my
like five matches
and this open division it's like local
black belts all levels you know how like
obviously not world world beaters but
high level guys
um how long have you been training thank
you you ready two weeks two weeks two
weeks yeah just so right wrestling since
i was 12 wrestling since i was 12. uh
but jiu jitsu two weeks would you say
when you were wrestling you were that
dominant too
no no i was i was like uh i was good in
high school
i was like seated seventh going into the
state tournament which is in new jersey
jersey is a really tough state
tournament um i didn't play so i was
seated seventh going in uh my first year
of college i gained a bunch of weight
because i was like i felt like i lost i
feel like i lost instead so i was weaker
how much are you talking about how much
50 pounds
in like in like eight months so i went
from
so i went from cutting right i know it's
it's a lot and this is natty
by the way right so i i went from
cutting from like 185 to 170 right
uh and then immediately after states i
blow up to 220. it takes me like six or
seven months right i've been hitting the
gym like crazy so yeah so the day after
states i watched the movie uh pain and
gain with like wrong oh yeah
yeah and i was like i'm gonna lift
weights yeah wait that movie what part
of it inspired you oh and it changed i
think it changed my life yeah because i
was like i was cutting i'm sick i'm same
height i was scanning uh to 170 so it
was like a string bean you know yeah
super because you're what six i'm like
six two six three i would just say
you know six three from far okay yeah
for sure six new shoes yes
yeah so uh i watched him i watched a
movie paid in gain and i was like all
right gotta get a gym membership so i go
i start lifting i watch all these videos
on youtube like how to get big and
everybody just said the same thing just
eat a lot eat your body weight in
protein
and lift heavy weights so i've been
doing that for seven years i look like
this now i feel like the gains that i
made like in the first like
like six or eight months was tremendous
and it's just been like a slow rise
after that um
but yeah i think the
i gained all that weight in in hopes of
helping my college career when i was
wrestling and and it really helped me
tremendously because i felt like i kept
the speed and athleticism that i had at
170 pounds all the way up but um at 197
because i cut from 220 to 197
and uh you know i did pretty good in
college i was i was ranked nationally
but i was never like never national
champ or nothing i was like i would say
i was good enough to move up in
divisions like maybe go d1 and have
success there um but you know after
college after the first year of college
i was just like when i once i made a
couple bucks once i made any money
modeling i was like i can figure this
out yeah yeah i was super against like
having a job just because my dad was
like uh my dad flips houses and it's
like uh kind of a real estate agent not
real estate agent but like developer or
something yeah
yeah like he he would buy a cheap house
fix it himself sell it and that's how i
made uh majority of his money so i had
the mindset was like i don't need a job
to make money so i think
you know that kind of uh
college to make money the college yeah
yeah i mean my dad is like a eighth
grade student and you know
he did well from there yeah yeah what do
you think it is then cause that's so
interesting where um you know it makes
sense if you got someone like like dc
right like he's olympian if he goes into
jiu jitsu it's like for sure you should
probably start pretty high right and i'm
talking about daniel cory from the ufc
but if you were like
good and wrestling but not like top dog
like what do you think it is either
about yourself or about the way you saw
opportunities in bjj that made you
become one of the top dogs in bjj um i
think
first of all i think the the wrestlers
that are top of the world they're you
know gold medalists and stuff i think
it's harder for them to transition
transition to jiu jitsu because
you have to start losing in order to
start winning so like those guys go from
being the best in the world in their
craft and then they go in the jiu jitsu
gym they're getting leg locked by this
nobody and it's like what's happening
here so it's really hard for high level
super high level guys to deal with that
because they have like a ego kind of
yeah it's an ego adjustment yeah so me i
was like i was used to losing but i
mean
yeah it's true like i've lost many times
in life in general uh but like
i think it's always easier for me to
shut off the ego and say like all right
i if i can learn i ca i can do this
better
oh i see so almost not having like this
the weight of the crown so to speak made
you be able to like learn much faster in
the new sport yeah i i would say so i
was surrounded immediately by like
pretty high level guys so i was always
asking questions and stuff
but i always found that i had the
tendency uh in training to become the
best person in the room so like no
matter where i was whether it was like
high school practice or uh you know
college or off-season training
i would find the best guy in the room
i'm like and i would understand that in
time i could learn and beat this guy and
that was my mentality so as soon as i
started jits i was always searching for
the toughest room in the area where did
uh where do you think that mindset came
from
um definitely wrestling like uh
you know i want to say in
in high school i would train an off
season uh this place called uh seagulls
wrestling club
and uh just ransom buy some local guys
but it will always teach us about the
mentality of winning like you have to be
consistent you have to uh like even if
you lose you know sometimes you have
short term you have to have short term
memory or sometimes you learn from it
um i think uh different ways of dealing
with adversity and and understanding
like my coaches would tell me in high
school like listen like
keep training you can beat this guy in
practice and you beat this guy in
competition so
i think they kind of drilled it into us
uh throughout my wrestling career and
it benefited me benefited me for sure
yeah yeah um so when you like um so you
did a little bit in college you decided
yeah this shouldn't for me um you
started going more into like the working
field um during that phase were you
still training
um i was so when i was working
and before jets i was training like
wrestling like i would go to like a
local uh high school
or i go to like a community college i
would train train with the guys i train
for wrestlers so i would still like you
know uh work on my craft
um was that regularly though like
multiple times a week or it's just like
every once in a while uh yeah i would
say multiple times a week like wrestling
season is only a few months throughout
the year so yeah i would do it multiple
times a week
i was i was addicted to wrestling since
i started like i would i would think
about it every day um so i always knew
like even when i was in wrestling i was
thinking about it i could never get off
my mind like never a day went by that i
wouldn't think about competition or just
something that had to do with wrestling
damn wow speaking of uh like your love
for violence
when when did you first realize that you
loved violence
my so my first wrestling practice uh
like i'm like 12 years old and we're
teaching they're teaching us headlocks
right and at the beginning of practice
that already sounds yeah
at the beginning of the practice uh
they're just showing us technique and
and stuff and then at the end we go live
and right when we start um
i i think i get headlocked and then
immediately after i stand up and
headlock my training partner it was like
this huge throw guys his feet goes in
the air his back lands on the mat and i
was like after practice i was like
this is the hardest thing i've ever done
and i need more of it so i think that
was my first taste of like uh
aggression or or just like realizing
that like if i learned it a little bit
i could beat this guy up that was very
attractive to me
what drew you to
to wrestling at 12. because like you
know that's
i think i i always find it really
interesting for people to like wrestling
because it's not at least you know it's
not something that's televised like nba
or nfl so those it makes sense i want to
be a football player i get it you watch
it on tv all the time right like it's
glamorized yeah i feel like you know
like wrestling and then especially like
before like when ufc super mainstream
it's like you have to even learn about
mma to know okay another discipline is
wrestling so how did like what got you
into it in the first place so uh i grew
up
in um clean new jersey right so
uh developing a bunch of kids and stuff
one of my main friends when i was
growing up uh his dad was a wrestling
coach so we played we played football et
cetera out front and he was always
telling me like dude like you know come
come train come to practice i was like
no you guys wear tights not for me yeah
that's too girly yes i get it some of
every manly guys you guys know i know i
can't do the tights no no no
so i go um yeah just like training just
playing with his son and and he was like
all right like you know come in i go in
eventually and start training with them
and it was great but one thing i did i
did notice like when i was young is that
i would just try harder than people
then all my friends like like whether
we're playing games or whatever they
would always be like like stop trying so
hard like you're doing so much like
you're super competitive competitive i
would just go i would just put that
extra effort you know when kids are
playing basketball playing 50
playing a win oh you're that guy we're
like yo chill out and you're like
beating everyone up for sure it's a lot
better now because i'm mature but yeah i
mean the the younger days it was uh
hyper competitive i would say for sure
wow
so during like um the years i found you
you were uh being coached by what a lot
of people regard as one of the greatest
like pgj coach john
donahue
how did you find him and how did like
that whole squad assemble okay so um
when i met jay robuto right guy from
south jersey bjj he would he had
contacts with uh with
essentially all the best grapplers and
grappling coaches in in the
in tri-state area really jersey new york
philly
um
i would the south jersey bjj is
affiliated with um henzo gracie and john
trains on the trains at hands of gracie
that's where he coaches at right
um
eventually i got a private or jo or
jay bought me a private with gordon i go
up there i do a private um after the
private gordon's like hey you should
come back tomorrow for practice
i go and gordon ryan the grappler um i
go i go back for practice have a good
training session and they're like hey
you should keep coming back so i took
that as an invitation i just never left
every day i took i drove my car [ __ ]
three hours up three hours back wow yeah
i did that i did that six hours a day
for
for about a year straight about five
days a week are you working at this time
i'll do a little bit of modeling um oh
[ __ ]
uh i think i stripped for a couple of
couple weekends trying to make some some
gas money you know we got to revisit
that but
we don't gotta visit right now
how was that like how did you get like
sounds
how did that thing oh i think i had
another bouncer that was well that was
shrimp and he was like dude like make
good money make like 500 bucks a night
and you know dance for some
bachelorettes i was like all right no
problem um i did that a couple times
what what what like you weren't even
like
i mean i was like no no no i know i know
what i got you know yeah yeah i could
provide right yeah yeah yeah yeah
so it's amazing yeah i actually i had a
uh i almost moved to vegas right because
oh [ __ ] yeah i actually filled out an
application for chippendales on my 21st
birthday
um and then i go back home like two
weeks later they hit me up and they fly
me back out for an interview
or audition and i get the job i was like
all right what was that audition like
did you just have to wear a little bow
tie and that was it so i i take my shirt
off i have shorts on i really just shake
my balls in front of these people for
like
15 minutes and they're like 15 minutes
this is maybe less maybe like five yeah
i was like yo i think they took
advantage of you dude
they got a free shot did you gotta
practice a routine or you just
freestyled it or no they like uh was
just a bounce
bounce
the good stuff it was a good stuff
so uh they put they brought me to a show
the night before so i had an idea like
what was going down and then the morning
after i didn't know an audition and uh
yeah i mean they just kind of like
choreographed like something real quick
and i just copied it
i got hips you know i can make it happen
i like that good for you man wait when
you were watching this show though were
you like i can't [ __ ] believe i'm
doing this or you like no i'm gonna get
this [ __ ] money
yeah and i was like i'm gonna get this
yeah i really didn't do it because they
guaranteed me like uh it was like 60 60k
a year but plus
good money
just for and you only work two hours a
day oh [ __ ] the rest of it you could try
that's it yeah you work from nine to 11
p.m uh like six days a week and you're
good
but 60k plus they said you're like
guaranteed like 50k in tips or not tips
but like in other stuff like photo
shoots and yeah yeah yeah other other
things like that so i was very i was
definitely considering enticing for sure
i was like 20 at the time i was like i
could make this happen
but uh
how did we get
here that's interesting yeah yeah no
it's super interesting um when you say
you like you go a hundred percent did
you go 100 for the audition too
i mean i'm gonna beat all these guys hey
i mean they wanted me
they want to be bad i say that much
that's [ __ ] sick okay wait no i know
how we got here because i was asking um
if you were working at the time because
you were like driving three hours from
home to yeah
no it was not working i quit like i quit
the home depot quit the mounting because
training was like i had to leave at nine
practice at 12
um and then trained for like four hours
and you know three hours home so i had
no time uh but i would make i would make
uh some money on online like maybe i'd
sell like 50 beanies here like some
t-shirts like just what kind of beanies
are teeny uh
uh yeah like what what are these beanies
well it would just be like uh like
before i started jiu jitsu i had like 30
000 followers on instagram
from from like the modeling also yeah so
yeah so i would like just put my name on
[ __ ] i was literally just trying to buy
gas yeah so i can get to get their
practice damn you're a hustler dude you
had to make it happen
yeah um but it was fun i mean i met john
like you know through that through
through gordon through that private and
more more even more than a coach he was
like uh like the team psychologist like
or a psychologist
it's one of those words yeah yeah yeah
um so he would like he'd be really good
at knowing like what to say when to say
to have our us like mentally peak yeah
although we're doing all the proper
techniques and stuff we'd have like the
the mental aspect down and i think that
made uh that made competition much
easier
wow um so like you're devoting a lot of
time to this right like what was the
what was like the end game for you was
there even any or you just like i
[ __ ] love it i'm just gonna do it
yeah i mean i would do jits every day um
just because i love it but now it's a
job and and i have uh i have goals i got
i want to be the best grappler in the
world i think that's entirely possible i
think uh it's just going to take time
and
more time really i'm dedicated i do i do
all the steps necessary to to make sure
my that's what my future looks like yeah
um but i mean i guess more so in the
beginning right because like you just
got into it is are we talking about like
maybe a year yeah like most people
i think um when you have a guaranteed
jackpot or pot of gold they're like oh
yeah i'll do like i'll climb this
mountain to get there right but for you
it's like who knows what's what's gonna
happen and you're just like you know
what three hours yeah three hours back
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] that's a whole
day yes like i turn down the chip and
know stuff like you know if i i can make
six figures you know doing that no
problem but i'm limit i feel like i was
limiting myself they're like they're
saying listen we're only going to give
you this amount and you can you can make
tips whatever but you're set at this
this amount of money so that was that
was like
also like in college and stuff i always
had the mentality i'm like i'm gonna go
to school to get a job to tell me how
much money i can make that's not like
it's not interesting to me that's it so
um the jiu jitsu honestly once i first
started it
and i competed i was like i want to be
the best of the world so like definitely
from day one that was that was my goal
so i was just always trying to figure
out how to get better training partners
how to get better coaching where should
i go when when to do it and uh
were you just like money i'll figure it
out like these people are obviously
living off of it yeah i figured out like
it wasn't it wasn't terrible for me
because i have a great home life like my
parents are good um like
i feel like it's harder for people if
they have a tough home life like you
can't just go back to your parents house
and sleep yeah you know you know like i
had the comfort the comfortable uh i had
the comfortability of like if i fail you
know i could go back to school you know
parents still love me i'm good
um that's awesome but yeah i mean my
focus money-wise was just to make enough
so i could buy food get gas to practice
and back um and i was like all right
once i have some jiu-jitsu success then
you know i'll take it from there
honestly i didn't make really any money
to like i won trials and then you know i
was able to like kind of live off live
up by myself after i uh placed an adcc
this podcast is brought to you by my
favorite zip recruiter if you've heard
our podcast you've heard me raving and
ranting about ziprecruiter and how i've
used it and how i love it and how it
saved me so
much time
ziprecruiter is like a family member or
a friend or
um
a partner right that helps you
live life and makes life easier for you
so i remember when i first got pregnant
with taika
um i was still you know online and
running my businesses and i'm like holy
crap how am i gonna do this but
thankfully i had my mom in my corner who
was there to help me babysit to guide me
through my pregnancy to guide me through
the first time being a mom and it was a
lifesaver because not only does she like
instill so much knowledge in me but she
also saved me so much time so that i can
have my hands literally in all the
things i had prior to having taika and
that's what i feel like zip recruiter is
for business people
it's like if you own a growing business
and need to hire ziprecruiter makes
hiring so much easier because they do
the work
for you and right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com
slash get close zipper cuter uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates
with your job post you can easily review
these recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply additionally
ziprecruiter has a complete
suite of tools that makes it easy to
filter review and rate your candidates
one of my favorite tools by the way that
i've talked about so many times four out
of five employees who post unzip
recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first
day can you imagine that like
amazing
guys don't sleep on it because i did say
you can try it for free
in fact the hardest thing that you have
to do is to remember our special url
which is ziprecruiter.com
get close
that's where you're gonna get the zip
recruiter for free so again
ziprecruiter.com
slash get close g-e-t
c-l-o-s-e
thank you very much
that was like you know was it uh so with
trials why is that a big deal so why did
it change for you so adcc trials it just
gives you like a bit of recognition um
in order to make it into adcc which is
the olympics of jiu jitsu you have to
win the north american trials uh i was
able to do that in like eight months so
once i went holy [ __ ] yeah
it was fast it was very fast i'm not
just 86 you better watch out eight
months swing all through man
that's tight yeah yeah it was cool and
then uh so once i won the trials i was
able to like you know make a couple
thousand bucks from like competition and
stuff and i'm not tied down to any
contract so like i don't like i compete
when i want to compete like i could have
four competitions in a month i could
have one two
so uh at the time i was competing a lot
i was doing like you know three or four
months for months at a time so i was
able to save up enough money get my own
place up in up in new york or north
jersey and then um
and then adcc happened
uh i got silver and then
kept competing a lot what was that like
uh because you're like fresh meat to
this space you know yeah so i did like i
want to say like 14 months is when adcc
world championship happened and i was
like i was like the lowest seed going in
there because you know they see they see
people accordingly according to like
skill and stuff or even like their prior
performance exactly prior performance
yeah so i was like there's 16 guys i was
like or 30 32 guys something like that i
was a [ __ ] last seat so i got a
really good guy in my first match
everybody process to even getting to the
last i'm sure you've got to do all kinds
of qualifying tournaments so even just
actually so the the sport's a little bit
different like in the olympics for
wrestling you have to win multiple
tournaments even make it to the olympic
trials in adcc there's only one
tournament although there's you know 200
people in the weight class
like this weekend we have 80 cc trials
in vegas there's over a thousand
competitors and there's only five weight
classes whole so how many matches are
people doing a day so i mean i feel good
i think to win it if you're gonna win it
you're probably gonna have like
uh eight or nine matches in the two days
you'll probably have four in the first
day
and maybe four or five in the second day
damn yeah so you have to like you have
to win like four matches to even make it
to the quarterfinals so it's very so
every uh it's a busy weekend but man if
you can do it you you're one of the best
grapplers in the country and then you're
in the bet the biggest grappling
tournament in the world so it's kind of
a shortcut like
i like the fact that you can be anybody
and compete at adcc trials and if you
win you're in yeah that's dope yeah
because it's not like a
specific pipeline like you gotta go to
this high school to go to this college
to get into the nba it's just like you
just walk on and if you beat everyone i
like that yeah yes gangster it gives you
it gives you a freedom like yeah uh you
know the i feel like wrestling is so
difficult like there's just so many such
a process to get even to the trials it's
like you're you're 80 matches deep in
your run down from this world-class
competition and then you have to go to
do trials it's like here you can bang it
out in a weekend and man you're you're
top tier if you make it happen that's
crazy so yeah let's go back to when
you're the last seed
what was that like being like like the
rookie on the scene and you've only been
training for eight to 13 months and
there's obviously a lot of like legends
around you did you even know these
legends because you might not have even
known you would have just been like
they're like dude you know who that is
and you're like nope
yeah
yeah these guys were like superstars you
know like especially in in the in the
jiu jitsu world but like i didn't i
never focused on like watching their
matches or anything because i feel like
if i watch my opponents compete i'll be
thinking about like what they're gonna
do like you know what's their their game
plan stuff as opposed to just thinking
like all right i'm just gonna take this
guy down stay on top take the back choke
him so um
i want to say my first adc world
championships i had like
very limited knowledge like i could only
take the back and choke an opponent i
didn't have anything else so
the game plan was very simple for me it
was like hand fight wrestle that's where
i'm good at
get on top and stay on top
so against much bigger opponents i knew
i could wear them out with my hand
fighting later on in the matches later
on in the match and then you know try to
take advantage of them uh as time went
on my first match was against a guy
named muhammad ali six foot five 260
pounds
shredded right huge behemoth of a guy um
and i honestly felt no pressure just
because
i was like all these guys have the
pressure i'm the new guy i'm not
supposed to even be here wow what a good
mindset yeah and i was like i was like
these guys have all the pressure i'm
gonna go out there i'm gonna do exactly
what i do every day i'm gonna hand fight
i'm gonna wrestle i'm gonna get on top
and i'm gonna do what i can
and uh first match goes down i throw him
at the end i get my hand raised
and i'm like all right go back to the to
the locker room and get ready for my
second match [ __ ] yeah how far away was
the second match i can um i want to say
like uh maybe 25 minutes oh my god so
it's a 15 minute war i have like 25
minute break and i have to go right back
out for battle and it was like
i wanna i would i wasn't i wasn't nearly
as nervous as i thought i was gonna be
and it's honestly because i wrestled so
many matches like i've had like hundreds
of wrestling matches and i've had crowds
where it's like you know five ten
thousand people in in the tournament so
like an event like adcc which is you
know it's a world-class event i felt
like i've been in that environment
before so i was easily adapted to it
damn yeah when you won the first adcc
was it with john donner yeah so i was
training with john
um the first cdcc for
maybe like six or or
oh i got i would guess i guess about a
year right maybe like nine months to a
year i was training with him
consistently like
uh three to five times a week then once
i once i you know had success in 86 in
adcc world championships i was able to
get my apartment and train with him you
know seven days a week no problem but j
uh john you know changed my game he's a
uh
super knowledgeable you know he's the
best jiu jitsu coach there is um but
again like i was saying earlier like the
psychological aspect that he gave to us
was very beneficial like i always felt
like
i always felt like he would he would
tell us
he would tell us like he'd make us aware
of where we're best at and and just
reassure us is that like if you get to
these positions you're gonna have the
best outcome possible
with him being the best coach what was
like the reason why you guys like parted
ways
uh we parted ways it was uh a few
factors um once we once covert hit we
moved to puerto rico
the team
wasn't really getting along too well in
puerto rico just because uh we had some
just like some inner issues and stuff
um and it was honestly a lot healthier
for us to split off and do our own thing
so we we came here to uh or we came to
austin austin we set up uh b-team
jiu-jitsu in in austin training out
there now um
john still has a couple of guys that he
trains with in in austin but on a
separate side of town because they moved
to austin too right yup yup honestly
austin's uh i would say the capital for
jiu jitsu in the us i mean it's got to
be it's got
multiple schools um really high level
guys everywhere you go
and uh yeah i mean
like
we we separated because it is definitely
more beneficial uh to go our separate
ways we're just having a little bit
animosity in the room and it was it was
taking away from our ability to learn
and progress
yeah that's really mature to like point
that out and just be like yo like this
isn't a healthy environment for people
because like you have to keep in mind
like everyone's coming in like with
different backgrounds different mindsets
and stuff and i think that's very
natural
yeah it's uh you have a when you have
too many lines and one then it can get
rough you know like uh
yeah that's all i'll say for sure who
coaches you now or do you ever still
like
ask don or her for help or anything like
that so i honestly i have a team full of
my coaches so like um the team that i
was with uh it was
you know the full dds was uh gary tony
gordon ryan
uh john danaher
uh ethan crellistein
myself nicky rod um craig jones nikki
ryan damian anderson
and um essentially five of us are still
together and like you know two or three
are separate during their own thing so i
have have the same coaches that i always
have excluding john and gordon i have uh
craig jones i have damien anderson nikki
ryan ethan foreign so these are guys
that like although i was in in
in uh you know practice with john like
john's running the session every day i'd
ask these guys questions like like i'm
i'm the kind of guy that have to be
one-on-one in order to learn if you're
teaching a class i'm walking back and
forth i'm wandering my mind's not my
mind somewhere else if i'm one-on-one
i'm hyper focused i'm learning
immediately
and that's so i still have extreme
progress because i understand now like
what questions i need to ask
and um how to ask them and then i have
the tools like my training partners are
also my coaches so like i learn like
just as i feel like children do the same
thing they learn from their peers
um maybe more so than than their
teachers so you know i'm constantly
learning from my peers and i feel like
no matter how much i learn i'll always
have more more knowledge again
damn that's dope that is dope um was
there ever a time
um outside of the gym that you were like
um you ever had to use any of your
wrestling or jiu-jitsu yeah so when i
was when i was bouncing right
the violent stories yeah so that before
jits though um
when i was bouncing in you know this
into in this intermediate section of my
life
um the second weekend i was bouncing
we're like clearing all these college
kids out like i go home you know it's
midnight we're close
to 3 a.m whatever um
these guys were getting route they were
getting like angry they were we were
trying to close the bar down
as i'm escorting these guys out one of
the
one of their friends like sneaks behind
me
and grabs my neck by the back right oh
no so i turned inside of him and i
landed like a belly to belly body lock
pick him up put him on the ground yes
right he slammed his ass
right and one elbow to the face and he
starts [ __ ] season on the ground
yeah so that that was rough but uh i
mean
season
maybe that would have helped but uh
but yeah it's it's honestly fighting is
so dangerous especially like outside of
like a sanctioned environment yeah
if you fight on the concrete like you
had hits of floors yeah that's bad it's
very bad yeah so like i only elbow him
just because he choked me that's kind of
like you're trying to kill me you know
so
i had to put him away but that's really
only time put him away
yeah that's really oh also all right
there's this one time too
like
they're all coming back yeah i so like
the day
the day i met my girlfriend's parents
right um we're in there we're in their
yard and they're like
her brother was there with his friend
his friend is a his friend was my high
school
uh football coach i played football like
freshman year he was like assistant
assistant coach
he's drinking and stuff he's like
talking about my wrestling skills and
whatever he's like well honestly i could
beat you in a fight because i played
football i'm like i'm like
i'm like uh i'm not interested no no
problem he's like oh well we should box
oh my god i'm not interested like if you
want to fight that's one thing but i'm
like i'm not going to box you you know
he's like he's like ah we should do it i
was like all right we go down we go down
to the grass in front of your
girlfriend's parents house
outback
everybody's watching her family were
they like into it though they were like
yeah you should do it
they were like i think they were pushing
him because they didn't think he was
going to like oh so it was like funny it
was like funny at first it maybe i don't
know i for me it was serious immediately
like you're challenging me you know you
can't but no one's stopping it like oh
okay this is cool this is i think they
were curious oh okay i don't blame him
i'm curious because he's he was bigger
than me he was he's six five he got a
few inches on me a couple pounds yeah um
so immediately uh we go down to the
grass i was like listen like
i tell him again like i'm not gonna box
you i'm gonna fight you if you put your
hands up he's like all right let's go as
he puts his hands up i take a shot
and i break my right hand on his face
yeah i hit him twice with the right hand
each each eyebrow was just shredded
bloody broken hand and after the second
punch i grabbed the neck and i look at
him in his eyes and he's like he's like
stop stop i was like i was like all
right buddy i just i just walk away
um
and that was it wait what is it no
that's not it what is the room doing is
a room like oh
yeah oh they were impressed they were
impressed yeah
yeah
nikki will come over anytime
i love it my girl's parents was like you
should probably marry this guy
all right
seems like i got it in with the family
we're doing it
oh [ __ ] this is a tight family yeah
um so those are the only time and you're
and other than that you're just like nah
it's really dangerous i'm not about it
yeah it's it's fighting just uh i'm like
i don't i mean now i'm like if i'm gonna
fight i better get paid for it yeah
but yeah fighting fighting is dangerous
number i mean the ufc guys are
they're crazy honestly getting in the
cage is like uh like i'm i'm a super fan
when it comes to fighting i watch them
all the time big ufc fan uh but i think
it takes a different kind of
like mentality switch to step in that
gauge and say like all right i'm i'm i'm
gonna try to i'm trying to beat this guy
but like trying to kill him trying to
kill him right because that's what you
have to do it's a it's a sanction it's a
sanctioned fight it's a sanction you got
to try to kill your opponent
um i'm a big fan of it but i do
understand that fighters are a bit crazy
hopping in there would you would you
ever do it i would do it if it was like
i would do if it was like if it was a
substantial amount of money and the
opponent was like like really bad like i
was just gonna you know oh that's tight
you keeping it real
oh come on
i'm all about easy payday if i wanted to
fight i
i would either do it like that where it
was a really bad guy and a lot of money
or i completely dedicate my life and i
try to be the best in the world there's
no really in between you can't really do
both right like best grappler and best
fighter it's like so hard i think it's
the highest i think the highest level
grappler in mma is probably gilbert
burns super high level jiu jitsu
um and and you know world class fighter
but to be the best in both like it blows
my mind like
fighters trying to be the best fighter
because like i'm just trying to be the
best out of one subject and there's so
much to learn there's absolutely endless
knowledge that you can take in and learn
with jiu jitsu so it's like it's almost
overwhelming thinking about the boxing
the muay thai the the knees elbows uh
you know all the cage wrestling it's so
many aspects of fighting
that i would feel like it'd take a whole
nother lifetime to be where i wanted to
be in the cage where you would be happy
with yourself yeah where i'd be having
this i wouldn't be happy unless i was
you know ufc champ best in the world um
and it's hard to do i mean it's very
hard to do and especially my weight i'd
either be heavyweight with francis
linganu or i'd be just below with jon
jones
damn you're [ __ ] them both yeah cause
i'm like 235 yeah and and i have either
go
wait five years john jones is kind of
old
yeah you're the fresh blood never know i
think i'll peak later too i'm 25 now
maybe 30 i'll hit my stride where i'm
like
nice and jacked you know yeah yeah so
like out of all this badassery talk have
you ever felt like a [ __ ] before you're
like god damn i was such a coward or i
was ashamed of myself or like i felt so
helpless in this moment
i can't really
me neither never
never felt like that really you've never
felt like a [ __ ] before
i mean like i don't like i don't like
spiders
you know but i'm not gonna run away but
what about like four or something like
did you ever have like a bully like a
bull like he was 10 and you were like
five and that's why he became the
juggernaut yeah he is today it was just
out of your control you know i mean i
had a i had an older i have an older
brother that was you know this rough but
typical older brother you know nothing
crazy uh but i think i think because i
had older brother i was always motivated
to be better than him like what's a
typical older brother though because my
older brother
[ __ ] me up
is that what is that i didn't even have
an older brother but my best friend had
an older brother and he [ __ ] me up
yeah
i think we just uh yeah i mean like he
messed me up a little bit but it's a
five year difference so i always
understood like i get bigger i get
stronger
um
oh but nothing crazy like he didn't
bully you or anything no no nothing
crazy honestly uh what's crazy to you
though because it true because people's
definitions might be
like like for you if you got like tied
up and then they were like waterboarding
is that crazy or not that's like every
day i mean
i call that crazy yeah okay okay
yeah nothing nothing that really stands
out but uh i mean i feel like i when
once i started wrestling that's when i
was like i was like all right aggression
is good you know this is it gave me like
an outlet to kind of like express myself
in the most uh you know dominant way
possible
and uh you're not getting in trouble for
it yeah i want to say like more than
like an experience like that i look i
understood what hard work was from a
very young age like i was saying my dad
flipped houses well since i was
since i was three years old i was
swinging a hammer you know i was
every every day after school
or even you know before i was able to go
to school you know i'd be in the houses
i'd grab stuff from um and then when i
was able to do stuff i'd help them with
things learning um you know learning how
to flip a house uh in general
um my dad would always say like
you don't want to work as hard as me
your whole life right so like work hard
now and have a plan that way your future
is is set up so i always understood like
what
what the what the extremely hard workers
do and i was like all right i just have
to find a field to work this hard in now
and then eventually i'll be able i'll be
set
so i think just that mentality kind of
carried over to life and definitely was
beneficial that's cool that like
you were so smart at a young age and you
kind of knew like the path and almost
formula to the life that you wanted yeah
i was like
i mean
my dad flip houses like uh you know from
top to bottom concrete work you're in
the basement you're doing roofs all of
it so i was like i definitely don't want
to do this so let me figure out a way to
find something i love and just like put
put my put the same effort towards that
i'm just happy i found i found my outlet
because i feel like sometimes like you
know everybody has a journey but
sometimes like finding what you love is
is just as hard as it's so hard to do it
yeah is there um you know how they like
um
like musicians wanna be athletes
like drake's gonna he he wants to be a
basketball player so bad right have you
seen him like [ __ ] lifting weights
yeah yeah and then athletes want to be a
musician they're coming out like yeah a
time where they came out like the rap
song like is there another thing that's
like a secret thing that you secretly
wished you could do yeah i wish i could
sing
um but do you think though you you have
like you're recording you gotta type
studio
no no no no i wish i wish i had i mean i
said i'll i'll sing like in the car i'll
sing the shower what kind of songs are
we talking about
uh
soul oh nice yeah
yeah all right um but uh
yeah i mean i feel like i have to have
the looks or i could sell a lot of
records there's not the voice so we
gotta balance it out so let's say you
had a genie that was like okay
all right nikki here it is
i could give you the voice of like boys
to man or bride mcknight
but you're going to get your ass beat
all the time or you won't get
drastically all the time but all your
fights kill yourself you can't defend
yourself or you'll be half the weight
too or i'll give you even more
fighting intelligence and capability
but
you're extremely tone deaf i like uh
i'll keep the fighting ability now yeah
i'm pretty tone deaf as it is as it is
so it could it couldn't be much worse
um i i like uh i like going into the
room and knowing i can beat everybody up
in there it gives me it gives me love it
gives me confidence honestly yeah yeah
i remember being like working at home
depot i'd be like mixing paint and i'd
look at all these people around me i'm
like what am i doing here i could i
everybody kill everybody i could kill
everybody right and i i thought that was
weird uh at first but what's weird the
mindset or that everyone else is
incapable i thought that me thinking
like that was weird at first but
it's just who who i am like i always see
like yeah i don't think that's weird at
all that's weird yeah well that makes me
feel more comfortable yeah i don't think
it's weird at all i mean you're just
aware of what your capabilities are
right um
so then
i i get it you know i get it um i i've
i've done that a lot too like because
we're like in the fitness space right um
so then you just kind of see people and
you're just like oh [ __ ] like i could
beat her ass not like that
i'm not a fighter
i'm not a fighter but like i'm just like
damn like people really don't give a
[ __ ] about being capable yeah and that
to me is like like physically capable
and that to me kind of blows my mind a
little bit you ever been in a fight no i
never have really never never i think
it's because i'm i think honestly i
think it's because i'm a big [ __ ] and
like i think i kind of come off a little
bit intimidating to people i want to
fight you
no dude
i'll pick my fights i'll fight i don't
know um but i just got into bjj this
year um i've never liked any contact
sports like i played volleyball like
that's how little i like
that side of the net yeah yeah like this
and even in volleyball you know like
like we don't ever touch each other um
but then this year i was like dude i
gotta stop being a [ __ ] like i gotta
get over that mindset so honestly it's
pretty gross like what like what i do
every day like i've seen bro it is gross
i'm sweating on top of other men it's
disgusting even like especially in
austin it's humid oh dude like i look at
the mats when you guys are done i'm like
that thing just looked like someone
poured water i feel like it smells
[ __ ] gross and it's like
[ __ ] steamy i feel like some days i
go into practice
and i like uh i'll get i'll start
sweating i'm like so [ __ ] nasty i'm
just like i'm face to face with this
hairy dude and it's like yeah it's it's
rough it definitely takes took some you
know adjusting oh wait how you wrestled
what do you think i wrestled for such a
long time and still i have days where i
go into practice i'm like
just don't [ __ ] touch me you know
like it's like like if i'm if i'm on
bottom like that's one of the reasons i
really don't like uh playing bottom too
much because i have like having somebody
on top of you sweating down on you
not for me not for me yeah yeah i like i
i would grapple too like and practice no
rash like shirtless for for a long time
and now sometimes i put rash guard on
when i'm feeling like don't touch me you
know it's like it's like my insecurity
coming out yeah just the sweat and stuff
just the sweat and the [ __ ] other
people's hair it's gross i love i love
it to death i love it to death but if i
think about it too much i'm like this is
disgusting it is disgusting that's the
same thing that makes me like it though
so i wrestle with the hair and the sweat
no like so like the men inside
listening i wrestle in high school right
and everyone's going through puberty
right so there's times where like after
practice you see someone's face there's
popped pimples like whiteheads and blood
you know because you're just [ __ ]
grinding heads and all that
and that's when you think about it yeah
it's disgusting as [ __ ] you're like oh
man i saw this dude all day it was a hot
day practice is after school so this
guy's been wearing that shirt from
morning until now and now i'm going to
wrestle with this guy but then the
minute someone has your
life in their heads yeah it's all of
that just goes out the window so what i
like about it it kind of trains you to
go don't care about [ __ ] no it's
like [ __ ] in one second it's like ew
germs but the next the next second when
you're fighting for your life
nothing really matters gotta get out
yeah yeah yeah so that's that's like
what i really like about it yeah so you
guys are in the in the fitness like
space right how did you guys get your
start because you have obviously a huge
following what was like what was like
where did you get your first like
notoriety from ours is kind of like it's
[ __ ]
windy so we started out uh uh doing
short films so we're in the comedy space
okay that's where we started that's
where we got our biggest recognition
from so we started well bart started
this uh this comedy channel with his
other partner called just kidding films
and we were making a lot of short films
like a lot of satire that's why he would
dress like a woman like it was just all
comedy stuff i think like old school
living color chappelle show like that
kind of stuff yeah that kind of stuff so
then that's where we got our following
from and that's how we grew the fastest
and um we've always just kind of been
like i played volleyball in college i've
always been into like sports or like
lifting or like exercise he's been
lifting for years
um
and um
well you you tell it
i'm all like telling you you're starting
so you guys started it together
no so i started with um we weren't
together at this point but me and my
partner we started the whole comedy
channel
he had a huge crush on me though and
then and then we got together she was
working like a corporate job at a bank
and when me and my buddy graduated it
was kind of those like do we do the the
slow and steady thing that everyone does
when you graduate college find that
corporate job or do we pursue this
youtube thing full time that no one even
knows what it's about and i'm talking
about like 2009 you know
and so we're like [ __ ] it school will
always be there um because you know
going to even a community college you
see people that are like 40 years old
coming back like i was this i didn't
like it i'm gonna do this so i'm like
america is like the the king of second
chances you know so we're like [ __ ] you
let's do it uh full on in um both me and
my partner we both had jobs so we would
um do our job all the way until like
eight o'clock at night then monday
through friday from 8 p.m to 11 p.m that
was kind of like our training where we
would write funny things from monday
through friday and saturday and sunday
we would shoot them
and for like a whole year we finally got
the channel up and running
and from there um the shield's already
helping us at that point and slowly that
started to grow and i've always been
lifting so i think all the comments have
always been like like yo bart what's
your training program like what's this
and i'm like i don't know man i just
like to lift weights you know i don't
and um i knew a lot from reading and
studying but i was never like a like a
certified personal trainer
and then in the gym kind of still being
like competitive i was always like man i
always feel like i'm like the strongest
dude in here so i'm like there's got to
be a lifting competition so i just
googled like powerlifting just back in
like 2000 the end of 2012. i signed up
for my first powerlifting meet in
dude
2013.
did uh so he needed to cut weight for
this this uh meat that was coming up
that he only trained for maybe like a
month he didn't know what powerlifting
was he was like i know how to bench i
know how to squat yeah i didn't know how
to squat i know how to deadlift i saw a
squat bench deadlift i was like oh
nobody squatting back in the day i
mentioned deadlift and i'm like i'll
figure out a squat yeah so i'm just
teaching myself
so he was trying to cut weight from a
wrestling background he was wearing like
trash bags and [ __ ] all the way down
miles you know so i was like running
three miles before i was gonna lift oh
this is the only way i know how to cut
yeah so yeah i cut weight i did my first
meet i got first place hooked the
community was so sick well the community
was very very much white
almost no minority he's the only asian
guy i'm the only other like tan person
in the room and i was like holy [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] weird yeah it was like
an all-white place and there was me and
then like 10 of my other asian buddies
in the corner
yeah so i was like oh [ __ ] it and then i
fell in love with it and then uh there
was no powerlifting gym
and we decided to start one just kind of
like one thing i'm not even like that it
was more like uh so yeah he got into it
i started seeing chicks lifting heavy as
[ __ ] and back in that time
girls were like well i don't want to
lift weights because i'm gonna look like
a man right like we didn't under like
nobody really understood the science
it's not fitness isn't where it is now
um so like girls just want to do cardio
right but then i started seeing these
hot [ __ ] babe chicks like squatting
like several hundred pounds and dead
lifting 700 pounds and i was like i want
that i think that should stick as [ __ ]
um so he was like at this point we're
living in a garage and he's like hey do
you think uh like we can have like our
own little like gym inside this garage
and i'm like dude [ __ ] no like we barely
have any room to like live i was like we
don't need a living room we just get a
squat rack put in here we're good i was
like so at that point too we were still
like making these youtube videos working
from home like shipping out our own
merch like there was just no way so he's
like what if we just like rent a
container like you know like those like
those truck containers he's like what if
we rent something like that and we just
like park it outside the office
and then people heard about it and
they're like dude if you do that like
i'll pay you like monthly for that so
then we started going oh [ __ ] i think we
kind of have i think i think we should
start our own gym and the goal honestly
was just to have our own training
facility and have the members pay for
the rent and that's it because that
wasn't the main focus the main focus is
to you know produce films or like make
comedy [ __ ] so most most of your content
was youtube based yeah yeah
okay yeah uh when you guys are living in
in the garage what's your following like
bro is this is this your podcast the
[ __ ]
probably like a hundred thousand
followers on youtube oh really yeah so
like um i would say that a year
no so we started in 2007
and we probably broke a hundred thousand
maybe after three to five years i would
say and a hundred thousand back then is
not the same as what it is tremendous
though oh yeah i mean yeah back then
yeah yeah
yeah but we couldn't i don't think on
our youtube i don't think we could make
a living to have like a staff because it
was me her our director my other partner
we had four people and in the beginning
like the channel might make like five
grand and we're all we're splitting it
you know and we weren't even getting
paid yet yeah like we would like our
directors gave me on like a grand or
something and we were like still living
off our savings and it was yeah we were
like it's kind of like your start right
like where you're just like i love this
[ __ ] i'm gonna do it regardless just pay
for my guess yeah it was like that for
us where it was like so fun that we're
like we're broke as [ __ ] but we're so
happy yeah we're uh
at b team we started a youtube channel
but we're kind of learning like it's a
different algorithm like it's there's
different things that attract people
like i've been studying the guy uh mr
beast oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and it
seems like like all his videos grant is
like super high quality but like his
frames are super fast it only lasts like
you know a couple seconds per frame yeah
uh the thumbnails seems like you need a
really good thumbnail a really good
title for you to blow up yeah so i'm
learning a little by little
eventually we'll and we'll blow it up
you know
yeah i think ultimately if you're trying
to build uh blow up your youtube you
just gotta make stuff that the people
want and that's what's tough sometimes
because sometimes you want to make the
stuff that you want yeah but it might
not align with what they're looking for
so like for example when we're doing
like our early sketches
like when when you're doing these videos
like we're artists right so we want to
get our expression out and we'll do
something that maybe we thought oh that
was kind of cool and it would blow up in
views the smart theme would be let's do
another variation of this or make this a
series but we're so like like
quote-unquote artist about it you know
and then we're just now gonna move on to
something else so that actually limited
our growth versus just oh this does good
let's do more of this and i think that's
what mr beast does really really well we
have to pay attention to the audience
yeah
yeah i mean it's a fine line because you
also have to do [ __ ] that's really true
to you because i feel like that's where
the longevity comes because uh
we've seen a lot of our peers like um
not stick to who they really are and
they experience like burnout or like mad
depression and like their life seems
pretty [ __ ] miserable and we're like
oh [ __ ] yeah we're just gonna keep being
clowns on this side but yeah i think fun
fun sells like if you're generally
enjoying it like i think your audience
is going to recognize that yeah i've
seen the stuff that you're doing like on
your reels and stuff
excuse me where you'll like um pick up
on like trends and stuff and i think
that's [ __ ] smart
yeah i'm trying to trying to figure it
out so social media just seems like the
best way to like make a name for
yourself even if you're you don't do
anything if you can have an iphone and
make some kind of content you can figure
out a life for yourself yeah
yeah it is pretty tight yeah and then so
fast forward to
us doing like barbell brigade was only
supposed to just be a gym
we created like an apparel component to
help fund it you know like selling merch
and stuff but then that kind of took on
a life of its own
and then um
then i think we started getting
recognized from other people in the
fitness space which wasn't even part of
the plan like we weren't ever trying to
do something and go oh we want to be in
the fitness space we were just like okay
let's have like our own private training
thing and we'll give it a cool name and
logo because we just like those kind of
stuff
and then
the almost the fitness space kind of
sought us out and so we're like oh like
well then let's let's like collab and be
more involved and it kind of just kept
growing until what it is today yeah yeah
yeah i'm a i'm a fitness fan
you like fitness i like i mean i like
like you like good you like that more
you like the grappling more uh i have a
tremendous love for both i like i mean
grappling is number one because like the
idea of controlling someone human
against their will is pretty
that's pretty attractive to me yeah it's
pretty sick that sounds kind of fun yeah
but also looking
looking fantastic while i do it is is a
secondary goal yeah for sure i think
that's really marketable too i think
it's really smart for you to work that
angle yeah i mean i think uh
i'm trying to do like the bodybuilding
the crossfit the jiu jitsu like kind of
collide i've done some some like work
with like uh jason khalifa which is
really yeah i've seen that yeah yeah
yeah i think i think crossfit like all
benefit
jiu-jitsu or grapplers just because like
you have the
jiu-jitsu is two things right it's a
sprint at times but it's also a marathon
because you have you have the 15 minute
matches sometimes longer
and crossfit i see like guys can put up
you know tremendous weight they can also
you know run them out right run a mile
they can swim yeah so uh i think that
aspect of crossfit is is definitely
intriguing and can benefit jiu-jitsu but
like
there's something about grappling that
like no matter what you do
your cardio is going to suck unless you
grapple like i've i've rolled with guys
that are in tremendous shape
but they step on the mat for 10 minutes
and they're dead a tremendous shape in
terms of like physically like muscular
or shape in terms of like endurance i
would say i would say both i had i've
had like
endurance athletes uh people that run
marathons and stuff come by train and
like they're physically fatigued and
then i've had the strong guys you know
the power lifters and the bodybuilders
and stuff come and they're equally as
fatigued do you think it's because um
like so i'm new to the sport like super
new like i wouldn't even say i'm even in
the sport that's on you i am um but do
you also think uh the mindset also plays
a factor in it right because it's like
it it's one of those sports where it's
like you kind of have to relax
i think it forces you it forces you to
deal with bad situation situations so
where
uh maybe last month you were panicking
so you're using a lot of effort to get
out now you're thinking you're like okay
i just like pull this arm off slide my
hips to the right and now i can get out
so i think it forces you to think while
you're under pressure yeah um
and uh
yeah i think like i think stress is is a
huge factor when causing exhaustion yeah
if you can force yourself you can
understand or find a way to be calm in
the stressful situations then you'll
have you'll be better endured yeah so do
would you say that plays a factor in it
like with those people that don't
necessarily train i would say yeah most
definitely like if you if you don't know
like you don't actually know exactly
what to do you're just going to be
moving and cause a bunch of movements
and expend energy to just escape this
this certain position but if but if you
know what to do you're thinking
cognitively and you're like okay okay i
just need to do these few movements so i
can get to a better dominant position
uh definitely knowledge is getting in
jiu-jitsu yeah yeah so you're saying
that um about crossfit married to you
know jiu-jitsu and all that stuff to say
that like you're trying to put something
together
are you yeah oh yeah yeah for sure um do
you have any workouts like let's say
like uh i don't know you do something
with the barbell and then it's super
settled with like sprawls or something
yeah i so so i wouldn't say like sprawl
stuff but i would i mix bodybuilding and
crossfit a lot to where like uh i'm an
arm day kind of guy by nature yeah
that's my thing every day armbar what oh
arm date yeah
everyday arm yeah
so like i'll uh
i would say previously i've been lifting
for like seven years previously it was
all bodybuilding right just like a body
part or two a day
completely destroying the muscle try to
get big i'm as big as i want to be um
now it's about becoming
stronger for longer at the same weight
than i'm that i'm at
um so i implement things like maybe i'll
do two or three bodybuilding workouts uh
and then i'll do like an imam and then
i'll do like uh you know some some power
stuff some some deadlifts and things
like that um but i don't go too crazy
like as far as how heavy i'm lifting
like
you know i don't really move more than
like 225 but reps reps are my friend you
know for sure but i think it's better
for your sport i think it's better for
my sport it's better because it's not
about like how many times can you lift
500 pounds it's like can you move this
guy that's 220 around for 15 minutes so
i think that that kind of uh thought
process when i'm lifting i'll benefit me
and uh
it's fun like i i'm enjoying i've always
enjoyed bodybuilding but crossfit is
way harder than bodybuilding it's like
like you're you're not moving not only
moving weight but you're you have a time
limit or or like uh you know it just
forces you to push yourself a little bit
harder i'm a big fan of the imams i
think i think if you say like
every minute on the minute i'm going to
do this thing and then like all right i
have 30 seconds and then a few minutes
later you only have 20 seconds of rest
and it's like [ __ ] it does you it
makes you deal with like a little more
stress and it forces you to push
yourself and i also enjoy the the group
setting um competing with each other a
little bit yeah yeah like i'll do
crossfit i work out alone most of the
times but when i do work out like
sometimes uh you guys know tim kennedy
is right yeah big fan yeah i've uh i've
trained with him uh quite a few times
and when i'm with like him and his team
it's like you push yourself harder
because it's like it's not just you
suffering right like you don't like when
you're solo you can take a break if you
want to no one knows yeah but like
you're seeing this guy doing the same
thing right next to you it's like [ __ ]
all right can't stop gotta keep going
it's like all right i feel like puking i
feel like like i might pass out i was
like it doesn't matter you just keep
going yeah have you ever done a workout
like a imam with
uh khalipa and did he toast you or not
or would you guys kept yeah no he
toasted me for sure i we did an imam
where it was like uh
it was like some def some deadlifts uh
and then some uh some roads right yeah
yeah
um
i've never seen anybody roll
like jason kalipa i thought the i
thought the machine was gonna break i
mean every time he would pull you hear
the fan
dude it was it was crazy i've never seen
anybody pull over or a machine like that
but the first time i met jason
first time we worked out together we did
a uh
imam for 10 minutes it was 10 burpees
10 burpee imams and
i never did a burpee before it was
pretty rough [ __ ] you got breaks oh i
was trash i mean i made it happen uh
like i completed it but yeah it was very
hard the first workout i ever did with
jason it was like this imam with the
assault bike and you have to hit like a
certain amount of calories i forgot it
was something unreasonable though and
then you have to hit it every 60 seconds
and then every other thing it was this
thing called the um
i think it's called the devil's press or
something so it's like a burpee except
when you get back up after the push-up
you lift up dumbbells and i think you do
a clean with them so it's like a clean
burpee with dumbbells
and [ __ ] crossfitters hate themselves
how can i [ __ ] myself as i was slowing
down like i think he wanted me to hit
like 12 calories per minute or something
like towards the eighth or ninth round i
was getting [ __ ] tired so i was
hitting only like seven or eight and i
would look over at his bike and it would
start seeing like 13 14 15. i'm like
this full speeding up what the [ __ ]
this is crazy dude yeah he he's in
tremendous shape i mean i'm a big fan of
the crossfaders i just like when people
like
try very hard like if you're like it
blows my mind like the first time i
worked out with jason i i didn't know
people put out that much effort like i
was like all right i'm just i'm gonna go
in there i'm gonna put in work
and uh just the the level of effort that
he put forth it's like open my eyes it's
like all right i can i can push harder
yeah yeah sure i've recently seen you
boxing or like sparring what's up with
that yeah i mean i just uh just did that
for the content really
i was like oh [ __ ] is he gonna try to
either get into boxing a little bit or
is he trying to do like an mma space um
so i was like i just pulled up to uh the
views yeah
i just pulled i have some friends that
invited me to do like a boxing like
workout with them we just hit the bag
and submits and stuff but honestly i've
only done it like two or three times
and it's fun uh it's a good workout but
like i'd much rather spend my time
either doing the crossfit the hard stuff
or or training jits uh just because i'm
not like
like later on once i'm extremely
successful in jujitsu i get where i want
to be i'll definitely spend a lot of
time learning martial arts learning
striking and stuff like that because
ultimately i would really like to race
some fighters produce some ufc champs i
think yeah i think my style of grappling
is the best style to have if you're a
fighter
so
in the future when i thought once i
complete my grappling um
uh once i'm done grappling i definitely
want to spend some time learning gaining
as much knowledge as i can that way i
can be a really fantastic training
partner for fighters and and hopefully
produce some champions that's dope that
is dope it would be cool if like you
know right now
they have all those like influence or
celebrity boxing matches oh my god if
they start doing influencers celebrity
grappling matches
i'd box a uh an influencer i mean for
sure i just wanted one i'm gonna want a
box
i think i know any you want a box
he's like no
i'm not a fan of uh brain damage to be
honest like even training for boxing you
have to get hit so many times yeah yeah
yeah it's not not that healthy yeah
yeah um but you're
so with the ears right so bart he for
him he's like if i get him i'm just
going to keep them for you were you like
i [ __ ] love these yeah so
before i got cauliflower you're like uh
did you never did you always wear
headgear in high school or yeah they
make us wear them in um they make a
swarm in like competition but in high
school and practice you don't have to
you don't have to wear it so i'd go to
practice every day i'm like i'm going to
get cauliflower oh you wanted it oh i
wanted it bad and then i got it and
then i realized how painful it was it's
it's absolutely terrible it especially
when it's like fresh it's swollen it's
soft it's tender to the touch they have
to go train and practice on top of it
i had it the first time i had it so bad
that i'd put that i'm sorry i put the
head gear on and my ear would actually
push the headgear out because it was so
swollen oh my goodness yes it was very
rough does it hurt right now no no it's
a rock car now i could use these things
as a weapon if i need to oh my god yeah
but like uh so the first time um i
didn't drain it i just let it calcify i
was like all right i look like a badass
my life set yeah man that man [ __ ] man
[ __ ] yeah and then uh years later i
started jits and i got it again
and i was like i was like all right we
got let's start draining it and i had to
drain it like what is this draining prop
what is that what is that like
so uh it's full it's full of fluid like
i i can i have a no don't show me [ __ ]
it's uh so it's probably twice the size
of the ear it is now but
full of fluid and very soft spongy and
tender right so
essentially it's just like a broken bone
when you break something your body
floods it with fluid try to heal so when
it floods the ear you usually have to
drain it and pack it tight for it to uh
heal up i was draining it like three or
four times a week
for maybe like two months because every
time i drain it i go to practice i wear
headgear and jiu jitsu just because like
the ear was so bad and i'd still get hit
and swell up and it was rough honestly
it took months for it to heal and then
like i i think jits is worse for
cauliflower than wrestling like i
wrestled for years and only got it a
little bit and then i go jets and like
pulling out of submissions and and
things like that just
absolutely destroy your ears
and uh it makes me look like a badass
which is cool but definitely it caused a
lot of pain for sure yeah yeah yeah uh
yeah if i
guys if you ever see anyone or any guy
any girl with cauliflower don't [ __ ]
with them like [ __ ] with the person next
to them or something
not them unless they're a shorter older
man
either
um [ __ ] i was gonna say something and i
forgot [ __ ]
my bed
i lost it it's cool well we'll end it
there thank you so much for coming on
our podcast it was really eye-opening it
was cool to just like pick your brain
and hear like how you ascended this
journey and also where you want to go
and go ahead yeah no it came back to me
i'm sorry i know you're trying to close
it out um this is how i wanted to close
it out what was the the highlight moment
for you like what what match or what
moment where you're just like [ __ ] this
is glorious and it's been like the peak
memory
up until now and then we'll end it there
it could be a match uh like public yeah
or it could even be like something that
happened in private like training too i
would say uh
the second best yep i would say the
second best um
was winning trials right when i won
trials it was like i was like all right
i did this i'm in the [ __ ] biggest
tournament the jiu jitsu community's
ever seen
uh time to get to work right i was like
you get that russia dopamine after that
win and i was like on top of the world
for a couple days
and then
i would say the number one
was uh beating cyborg
um
in adcc right
uh when was this one this was 80cc world
championships 2018
semifinals match before the finals right
so i go to gauntlet i have muhammad ali
i have orlando sanchez huge guy oh yeah
360 pounds just massive human and then i
have cyborg right cyborg's probably the
best guy that i've seen so far
and uh everybody
people like there's no way this this
blue belt is going to beat uh cyborg
so i go out there i
do some good wrestling i don't take them
down and i get a bunch of like
advantages where like i'm on top i'm a
i'm aggressive i'm being the aggressor
right
um i get my hand raised
out of the decision i look over and he's
like on the ground he's like freaking
out there's a very iconic picture where
marcus bushesha is like
one of the best grapplers ever lived
he's staring at cyborg cyborg's on his
knees like crying to the refs and i'm
just sitting there with my hand up and i
think that is probably one of the most
iconic moments in in my career because
it was like
it was like no matter how long this guy
grappled i was able to shut down
everything he's ever done for the past
25 30 years of his career with just
a little bit of strategy
and
effort i said before i step out in this
match i'm gonna outwork him i'm gonna
get him tired and i'll make him break
and by the end of the match he all he
wanted to do was quit what uh what was
he crying about did you have an injury
no he was crying because
uh he he thought he won the the refs
decision but like all he did was just
i would i would uh i would attack
he would do a movement i'd re-attack and
that happened 50 times that much so i i
was attacking way more than around the
match there's no definite points or
anything that happened no like definite
movement i had like a cool throw uh but
that was a but besides that i was way
more active i was way more engaged
and um
i think that was probably the most
valuable win and probably the most
notable where people are like
like
damn i can't believe that happened
that's pretty cool
that level of intensity
does training reach reach there too yeah
i uh yeah if you train with me
especially consistently um i have a
thing where like when i'm training with
new partners i only give them like a
little bit because not everybody's that
durable and people understand like like
the kind of
uh effort i put towards training so once
once we train a few times you know i'll
usually start treating it like
competition get get rougher and get more
intense so you slam fools in training
too
or do you pick them up
most of the time i put them down gently
but sometimes we'll have
we'll have visitors that come in that
have to go real hard with right so like
be team jiu jitsu in austin texas i
essentially i put a hit out on myself i
was like no matter who you are if you
could come in the b team you could take
me down
free t-shirt right so i was that tight
is that the t-shirt the mexican ground
karate mjk mixing ground karate this is
a t-shirt so you guys listening yeah
come to b team if you take me down you
hold me down you get a t-shirt so i put
out a hit on myself
and every now and then i have some
college wrestlers come in i have some
big boys from out of town and i'm like
all right it's a go time how do they
come in like a martial arts [ __ ]
nation asian martial arts movie where
they're like you yeah now challengers
full samurai suit they come in
let's do this right so uh so yeah uh
long story short i've never given
anybody a t-shirt oh that is a [ __ ]
short ass story
yeah oh [ __ ] that's time where can they
get that shirt uh you can get it on uh
lincoln bio nikkiro247 or uh b team
lincoln biowas yeah that's tight dude
you're a real one thank you so much for
being honest
you're a lot of fun thank you
um and thank you guys so much for
watching we'll see you guys next week
peace